I'm generally pretty hardcore you know I
want I want a hard race I want to be
destroyed afterwards my dad to say with
so much my sons could be the first
platform one driver everyone kind of
thought yeah right we harness energy
without even noticing it and whether
it's good or bad my goal this weekend is
to win this race all the other stuff is
all just noise he's a British Formula
One racecar driver
currently racing with the Mercedes AMG
Petronas team
he's a 2008 2014 and 2015 Formula One
world champion he's the only driver in
the history of the sport to have won at
least one race in each of the seasons
he's competed in he's Lewis Hamilton and
he was my take on his top 10 rules for
success rule number one is my personal
favorite and make sure to stick around
all through to the end for some special
bonus clips and as always if Lewis says
something that really really resonates
with you please leave it in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
you
the first year yeah was the first year
like I'm at McLaren I've got the
two-time world champion he just won the
championship 2006-2007 he's got number
one his car would be number two because
that's how it it goes and I remember
sitting you know testing just studying
studying studying I've got to make sure
that I somehow what a match this guy I
believe in myself that I'm somewhere in
ma there's the speed to keep up and beat
this guy so I mean before the first race
Ron said in his office he's like you
know oh you know you coulda expected
don't be surprised if you have a second
behind Fernando in the first race we
don't know what that did to me aside I
was so what did it do like it just
boiled me inside because he will see
under that it and not undervalue me
because he obviously gave me the role
but he he he was not expecting me to be
able to answer to his special new guy
and so he said you expect to be beaten
yeah yeah and so um your life had not
been about expecting to be beat no no so
I mean I trained like crazy
I prepared he did beat me in qualifying
and he did beat me in the first race but
I finished just behind him third and
after that I I think I beat him in with
the next race no I didn't impede him it
may be a third race I beat him and then
I beat him in the championship at the
end of my first year my rookie year what
I do love is when I do a race and on the
edge the whole you know the last race
for example I was dead at the end I was
pushing so hard and really enjoyed it
that's what racing is all about I'm
generally pretty hardcore you know I
want I want a hard race I want to be
destroyed afterwards it doesn't matter
if certain you know of course I want to
win but as long as you put up a good
battle and you've given a hundred and
ten percent
you've left with zero you know it's not
like oh I had a couple percent left but
I finished the race I'm like I want to
be completely depleted off the race
knowing that I gave it my all and I
didn't make you know very many mistakes
and and then I can go home and proud
unfortunately there are people
the talent that don't have the money I
kind of look at it like if and if you
seen Cool Runnings when they tried to
raise money to go boss saying and all
the people that they approached just
laughed at them and you know the same
for us you know my dad to say would
become was my son's gonna be the first
platform one driver everyone kind of
thought yeah right but you know he kept
going and it happened you know we got
there so never give up me as a driver I
just grew I change I I improve all the
time through experiences not race by
race not just race by race but in life
and I'm always taking all these
different experiences positive or
negative extracting the best bits out of
them learning becoming older and wiser
I mean I'm 23 years old I think I'm
quite wise for my age I think I still
got a long way to go but but then when
it comes to driving I just I I excel I
I pushed beyond the limits when I'm
training I go beyond the pain barriers I
just do everything I can to make sure
that when I arrive at the racetrack I've
already got two three tenths on the
other guys I think we as human beings we
harness we harness energy without even
noticing it and whether it's good or bad
I think I harnessed all those different
experiences and that's cool you know
when the teachers were negative and with
those parents and I just kept it and I
kept it bottled inside and I use it on
the track my dad will always say you
know cuz kid would push me off the track
and I'd have a question I'll be like you
know I want to go and I want to go and
push that guy overall you know flick him
in the air or kick it or something and
you would say do your talking on the
track just don't say it and just do your
talking on track and that apply to
everything in my life's just do your
talking on a track so I get on the track
and I'll drive the wheels of the car
when I came to former one in trying to
get again to form all of us was tough I
had to win everything I was led to
believe a to win every championship so I
had to make sure that I studied about
the car every change that made that I
had to write it down and study it have a
cat
home of all the changes I made of all my
setups so when I got to film one changed
from Rob I know exactly what changes
that's going to make to the car and so I
had to really build up a good
understanding of mechanics and I think
you know when I got to McLaren my
fitness level had to take another step
to another level so I was training
ridiculous amount of hours a week and
which I hated and spending a lot of time
at the factory would sit down with an
energy had would have probably four to
five probably for engineering meetings
every day at some McLaren this is before
my first season after my GP to season
two to understand all the different
scenarios the race strategy is the tire
it tires the steering wheel there was
incredible amount of information I
didn't have to do it before before I
just get in the car in form of db2 and
and now I could you know do a couple map
read a couple maps trying to understand
where the tracks going and work with the
setup but form one tons and tons of
information on it and that was really
the biggest step that I had to make I
had a steering were to come and have to
study it I looked at it every every
morning and every unit try to close my
eyes and no web switches were and and
and obviously just getting up to speed
in my first eight test days I had trying
to catch get on the pace and not make
mistakes and have the fitness level to
just keep it up that was the biggest
episode for me and no I gots my first
race and you know I was fourth came
fourth in the first race I was ready
because I I really did know I can go I
look I couldn't look back and say I wish
I'd done some more that because I did
everything I could
the challenge of joining Mercedes is
obviously going to a team that struggled
for the last couple years they've not
won as many champion championships have
not been competitive in this era of of
car design you know that this era of car
design came out in 2009 and obviously
you have the top three teams that have
been there and now Lotus have also come
in and started competing and Mercedes
finished fifth in the championship last
year so it's taking a team that's
struggled and helping them to climb up
the ladder and get higher up so I want
to be a part of that owner getting there
and I want to help develop a car push it
in a certain direction I feel that I'm
good at and perhaps other drivers will
not ask you that maybe who knows but
taking that car out across the line and
winning is the ultimate goal how do you
prepare yourself with with to be so
focused to handle of all this massive
stress really it's um it's trying to
just remain focused on the job at hand
and then the task my goal this weekend
is to win this race all the other stuff
is all just noise and it's just I guess
it's just through experience kind of
been out to silence all that and stay
focused on what's the most important
thing so they'll be distracted by all
the media all the cameras you know I
mean there's tomorrow there's so many
interviews mostly with the same people
that we always have so I've been talking
to these guys for 10 years but and it's
often asking the same question that they
asked me the two weeks ago but obviously
they have something more to talk about
this weekend because the last race was
terrible but um I think it really is
just trying to I guess compartmentalize
really that that stuff put over here put
it in a box and then you know keep the
energy and your focus on the one thing
that matters most all that other stuff
does not matter what matters is me
team how we're going to get from you
know from Friday or you know Thursday
this week for example to Sunday standing
on top of that podium and you know it's
sleep it's what I eat it's what I spend
my time doing making sure I get to bed
early all these different things that
had to add up to it and sometimes you do
it all perfect and it doesn't go well
but that's life and you just hope that
in doing all the right things but it's
also trying to find a balance you know
you need to enjoy life as well you know
some sage angler my career will be over
and I want to look back and say I did I
enjoyed absolutely everything every
moment in the car every every moment out
of it that's fun every time as soon as
you put your suit on it's fun it's the
whole weekend's a complete blast and
although it's very very political and
very serious and everything like that
which you need to be because it's a it's
mmm it's it's immensely intense and
competitive but it's so much fun you get
in the car and I'm like a kid I know
what to do with it and and I'm like a
kid with a new toy hello I'm James
Corden this is Lewis Hamilton hey I've
got one lap to ask as many questions as
I can
Lewis are you ready I'm ready okay on
your marks
fascism you're out oh my god I'm asking
me more than two zoos how many pushups
can you do
18:19 mb to 1995 who's your hero
the Formula one Oh
is one like me
you will be amazing
he's Manomet yes touch
right true or false you wear your helmet
in bed
do you ever play with your helmet that
you were gonna sing me a song so what'd
you say
okay okay oh my god
God favorite huh
Oh
Oh Mike we're down man
thank you oh it's amazing
I can't feel my legs
it's ridiculous
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Laghman asked me
to so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you or made a profile next leaving
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know what did Luis say
that really resonated the most with you
what is going to have the biggest impact
on your life or your business after
watching this video leave your thoughts
in the comments below I'm going to join
in the discussion finally I want to give
a quick shout out to Gaelic anneza
thank you so much guys I left for
picking up a copy of my book it really
really really really means a lot to me
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
when you build up to formal one you
obviously preparing to race but you're
not prepared for what comes along with
being a fun one driver the pressure of
such a big team sponsors media sitting
in front of sitting there sitting on
stage talking you're not prepare for
that you're not put through a school or
through other interviews for it so you
arrive in a deep end without being out
to swim and I mean I made a lot of
mistakes I got into obviously I was
quick on track that was no that was the
easy part
is everything outside but um lost the
first year in 2007 by one point which
was was you know depending on how
serious you take your job it was
emotionally traumatizing the first year
came back the next year somehow came
through that that experience and then in
that last race I had to finish fifth I
started third I think it was and I was
fourth fifth and then was probably like
six laps seven laps to go or something I
was down in sixth and the guy that was
ahead of me with Sebastian Vettel and
there was if you know I feel I feel if I
had to do if I couldn't do anything to
even to save my mother's life and my mom
was over there on the edge of the cliff
I had to pass him to in order to I
couldn't get past him you know I
couldn't get past this guy and for those
laps so we just wasn't giving up but I
could see that dream fading away and and
then the last lap some guy was on sick
tires I was on wets he was stumbling
there's quite a few of them were
stumbling I was overtaking cars here and
there I didn't I had no idea I was I
thought they're back markers the guy
came across the line and thought he'd
for a second hat was world champion and
then I came across the line 17 seconds
later and I crossed the line and I
thought I lost the World Championships
and my heart sunk
I I mean I was distraught and then like
I don't know why it took so long but
like 12 13 seconds later they told me
that's world champion and I mean I I
didn't know what the hell was going on
and I think just at the time after that
big whirlwind of media back at the
factory there was so much tension I
think I wasn't I guess I was just I was
only 23 so I
don't feel I was don't forget you know
growing up instead of hanging out with
friends on the weekends and you know
doing normal kids social life stuff I
was racing I was with adults so I missed
that a lot my that maturity growing up
stage and I don't feel I was mature
enough to really be able to embrace the
whole experience and enjoy it so I'd say
it was not a great it was this amazing
that I won the championship it just
wasn't wasn't able to enjoy it and
rolled into the second year the year
after that for example but the last two
championships have really I guess coming
of an age being able to really absorb it
enjoy the moment because so much work
has gone in from my family so you know I
don't take it for granted the the
opportunity that I have won there are so
many people that would cut their leg off
to be in my in my seat and do what I do
so I make sure that I just maximize
every time I get in the car I'm
representing my family every time I get
in that car and so there's nothing
there's no time for second place
of course those experiences when you
have those lows like the work losing the
World Championship only make you
stronger when you do or realize that you
know this heights and lows see once
you've had the low you appreciate the
house even more so and so particularly
frustrating for you this this season
I mean it's early days yet but it's a
killer season is it's terrible obviously
had a couple of amazing years the last
two I would say this is you know luckily
through the experience of the ten years
of racing you kind of you know you have
the ups and downs and I definitely think
these past five races have been
massively testing for myself my
mechanics from engineers I think each
time I see it as a challenge to rise I
see it as a challenge to you know I'm
gonna be facing the media right now but
I feel terrible I'm angry that I lost
the race or something like that
but it's a moment for me to the kids
that are watching - to me to say the
right things it's a moment for me to
lift my guys up who are probably feeling
just as much as me or you know back at
the factory who worked non-stop to build
my car there's so much going on and I
feel like sometimes I feel often
when I do myself want to do it right I
feel somewhat come out with so much
stronger and so I do feel this is just a
you know Charles and tribulations this
is a period of time of growth for me
that whilst there's always growth no
matter no I meant Nelson Mandela once in
when he was 90 his 90th birthday and he
said to me that he was still learning at
that time so I have a long way to go
hopefully I think the advice that I
would give would be to try and get as
much running as you can take your time
and it's so easy to just get ahead of
yourself and think you know I'm ready
for this I'm ready to take the next step
and you just got to take your time that
that was really the fortune thing I had
with all my support from my dad and from
that from Ron was just trying to make
sure that we didn't rush it and you just
take your time get lots and lots of
miles and get about lots of racing
experience wheel to wheel racing and and
utilize every second you get on track I
do everything I do I love jet skiing
going out with quad bikes motorbikes
surfing rock climbing pretty much
anything with an engine yeah I try to do
as many things that I can I'd like to do
water skiing I do wakeboarding and want
a skin so I pretty much do quite a few
things but those are the things that I
do too when my dad would be like you
shouldn't be doing any of those things
because you race off on one car you
don't need to do it but when you're not
racing you need something to keep that
that drilling and that hunger going